[Musique]
chacha guitare toro clavier ti bwa le
groupe mandarine et joue au nom de la
tradition et jusqu'au bout des cantiques
revisité qui interpelle plus d'un
on est à la page 20 trois anges sur un
air de jeane manson qui date de 1977 la
chapelle de harlem
[Musique]
à
oh
et ça continue avec noël à les manuels
page 37 sur un air de neko spirituel
when the saints go marching
[Musique]
pour retrouver dans notre musique
l'adaptation sur muna d'adaptation sur
akiyo nous sommes dans un bassin
caribéen nous n'oublions pas la
proximité et le negro spiritual et de
grosses pelles quand même ça nous un
petit peu bercé par rapport à nos
origines donc tognon aussi apprêtée
comme l'adaptation sur ses rôles à les
cantiques de noël chants sacrés chants
profanes une identité martinique
guadeloupe notamment
il ya depuis longtemps traversé les
océans
nombreux sont ceux qui font le voyage
pour cette ambiance
[Musique]
les chants de noël à la version
martinique elle c'est super grand bain
par exemple du snui on connaissait mais
la version classique et là avec le
rythme martiniquais c'est magnifique
c'est tout à fait différent mais là le
rythme dans la peau sa jeunesse est pas
un problème
c'est très festif ça nous change
complètement de leur tristesse de
mélancolie de région parisienne les
champs justement c'est très différente
chez nous c'est très très emporté très
joyeux très agréable pas moins d'une
vingtaine de groupes en martinique pour
tenir le rythme entre amis y voient de
la famille des heures de répétitions en
amont le groupe mandarine a ainsi amené
une quinzaine de soieries 7 m
[Musique]